une production du studio
SF bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast
où on parle de ce qu'on veut que nos
invités d' pH Quentin avec moi Dom plant
on sort de notre horaire traditionnel
pour aborder un sujet important et
d'actualité cette semaine on parle du
conflit israélo-palestinien puis en fait
de de de la guerre re Israël et la mar
de la frappe surprise qui qui est
survenue le 7 octobre dernier puis tout
ce qui en découle tout ce qui a amené à
ce on reçoit Laurence Deschamp la porte
qui est directrice au serium le Centre
d'études et de recherche internationale
de l'Université de Montréal et
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient et Sabrine
Amir journaliste qu'on a déjà reçu au
podcast qui était correspondante à
Jérusalem de 2016 à 2020 et qui est
conseilleur en communication au serium
aussi donc et d'ailleurs le podcast avec
sabrinomir qu'on a fait il y a 2 ans est
encore une référence très très juste et
très très à jour de ce conflit-là en
fait parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé du
contexte euh du conflit
israël-palestinien de de son historique
donc pour avoir un petit peu plus de de
de de contexte finalement pour
comprendre un petit peu mieux le euh le
conflit vous pouvez aller réécouter ce
podcast là et écouter bien sûr le
podcast aujourd'hui donc on a parlé
évidemment de de de ce qui s'est passé
la dernièrees semaine et ce qui amené à
ça euh les réactions de tous les
conséquences de tout ça euh qu'est-ce
qu'on prévoit pour le futur de ce
conflit là une question complexe pas
facile à répondre très
nuancée c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas un sujet
facile
puis nos sympathies à toutes les tous
les innocents toutes leur famille tout
les victimes de ce conflit là d'un côté
ou de l'autre aucun innocent aucun civil
qui qui devrait mourir dans des
conditions comme ça bien dit bon bonc c
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute ça roule merci d'être là merci à
vous merci c'est super apprécié de
j'imagine que votre horaire ces jour-ci
est assez dense est-ce que vous dormez
un
peu pas beaucoup dans mon casamp en tout
cas parce que je suis ce qui se passe
pass toute la journée les soirées
jusqu'à minuit je me lève à 6h du matin
pour vraiment rattraper ce que j'ai pas
pu voir pendant la nuit donc je me fais
un devoir de regarder ce qui se passe vu
que j'ai travaillé là quand même pendant
plusieurs années donc non je dors pas
beaucoup mais j'ai pas à me plaindre si
on compare avec ce que j'ens viv là-bas
sur place évidemment c'est ça non mais
je pense qu'on
s'inquiète on s'inquiète de ce qui se
passe dans le moment puis on s'inquiète
de toutes les répercussions que cette
gare là va avoir dans les 30 prochaines
années parce que on n'est pas sorti du
bois là hm hm ouais tu parles de 30
prochaines années tuentrevois c'est
c'est pourquoi 30 prochaines années mais
tu sais h en ce qu' a trait euh au
Moyen-Orient c'est sûr qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de conflits tu sais quand même
pour les gens qui sont pas spécialist
c'est des scoupon il y a beaucoup de
conflit dans cette région-là mais c'est
vrai que jusqu'à un certain niveau la
question palestinienne pour les experts
de la région semblait presque oublié OK
puis je vais vous donner un exemple euh
c'est que même en ce moment il y avait
plein d'accords de libre échange de
négociation diplomatique avec Israël
puis il y avait une are dans cette
régionlà où est-ce que c'était il y
avait une condition toujours pour les
pays du monde arabe pour les pays du
Moyen-Orient que ces choses-l ok ces
négociationsl allaient arriver à la
condition qu'il y a il y ait une
certaine résolution politique sur le
plan euh de la question palestinienne
que ça soit sur le territoire sur le
droit des réfugiés quoi que ce soit et
là on voyait que que ça si on veut les
testes d'Israël netaniao en particulier
avait plus ou moins réussi ok au regard
de la communauté internationale à
marginaliser la question palestinienne
et aller de l'avant avec des types de
négociation tout en les laissant de côté
on se dit ben écoute don peut-être que
c'est cette espèce de conflit là qui va
rester dans une
boîteon saina et moi on n jamais pensé
que ce soit possible mais ça semblait
gérable du point de vue de nthaniaou
Dison il y avait même ces accords là
d'Abraham que moi j'ai étudi par exemple
des accords diplomatiques avec des pays
du monde arabe qui permettaient d'avoir
des relations diplomatiques formelles
euh puis ce qui était marginalisé de
tout ce processus là qui puis à mon avis
des relations diplomatiques c'est
toujours louable mais ça ça ne régla
rien à la question politique des
Palestiniens et là on voit que
finalement
euh ben ça ça l' vraiment littéralement
littéralement est symboliquement explosé
et là on voit que c'est un retour à à un
Moyen-Orient où est-ce que la question
où est-ce que le conflit
israëlo-palestinien israélo Hamas en ce
moment si on veut plus précisément a
vraiment un risque de déstabiliser la
région euh puis ça c'est ces chosesl ne
se règlent pas en 2 3 ans h et on va en
parler encore longtemps parce que le
statut quo n'est plus possible
maintenant jamais israël va accepter de
vivre à côté d'une bande de Gaza qui est
gouvernée par le Hamas et on est en
train de réécrire une page de l'histoire
de ce qu'on là littéralement et Benjamin
netaniaou le Premier ministre israélien
l'a dit ça va changer le MoyenOrient
donc c'est c'est du jamais vu c'est
inédit ce qui s'est passé en Israël et
ce qui se passe en ce moment à Gaza et
ça va changer assurément à mon avis le
cours du conflit h HM si euh on veut
faire les choses dans son dans leur
ordre euh le Hamas qu'est-ce que c'est
et comment ils en sont arrivés où est-ce
qu'ils en sont arrivés le le le 7
octobre peut-être que je peux juste dire
un mot contextuellement sur
politiquement comment les Palestiniens
sont représentés puis ça c'est à l'aise
d'aller un petit peu plus en détail sur
le sur la hamass
donc si on veut il y a
comme trois entités politiques qui
représentent les Palestiniens qui sont
pas nécessairement vus comme légitimes
par les Palestiniens eux-même ok mais il
y a il y a ce qu'on
appelle le PLO ok le Palestinian
liberation organ
qui pendant un moment était même vu
comme une organisation terroriste mais
qui est devenue plus ou moins qui s'est
pacifié qui est devenu accepté sur la
scène internationale qui est maintenant
si on veut la représentation
internationale des Palestiniens donc la
il y a des états dans le monde qui
reconnaissent un état de la Palestine
comme comme un pays légitime c'est pas
le cas du Canada il y a un grand nombre
de pays occidentaux qui soutiennent la
position qu'un État palestinien ne peut
être reconnu qu'après euh des
négociations directes euh entre Israël
et les autorités palestiniennes on y
reviendra sur éventuellement sur est-ce
que ça va être possible ça un jour
est-ce que ça même réaliste alors en
attendant ils reconnaissent pas un État
palestinien mais ça ne change pas que le
pllo c'est un peu l'entité qui
représente les Palestiniens à l'étranger
c'est-à-dire à l'ONU au Canada on a une
délégation pas une ambassade parce que
c'est pas reconnu comme un pays du PL en
s Jordanie donc les Palestiniens vivent
sur deux territoires ok la S Jordanie en
anglais on dit West Bank parce que c'est
la banque du jour du Jourdin qui qui est
collé si on veut l'autre pays le plus
proche et la Jordanie et la bande de
Gaza qui est collé le pays plus entre la
mer et la péninsule du Sinaï qui
appartient à l'Égypte qui qui qui est le
territoire égyptien mais bon qui a été
au cœur de plusieurs gares dans
l'histoire et c'est pas géographiquement
lié là faut bien comprendre ça il y a
pas de lien physique entre les deux
alors si on veut rentrer ou sortir de la
bande de Gaza c'est très difficile il
faut passer par la la péninsule du sinï
ou passer par Israël mais c'est très
difficile pour ceux qui ont qui sont pas
israéli israéliens et pour la
sisjordanie selon les passages par
Israël ou plus facilement pour certains
Palestiniens par la Jordanie qui est
presque sa population à plus de 50 %
d'origine palestinienne ok alors il y a
des populations palestinienes sont très
grandes dans le reste de la région aussi
mais il il y a pas c'est ça il y a pas
de pas de
lien de se rendre d'un point à l'autre
c'est pas possible surtout aussi parce
que gaz sous blocus hein depuis 2007
donc les gens ne peuvent pas entrer et
sortir comme ils veulent il y a les
journalistes les diplomates les
humanitaires qui peuvent aller à Gaza
les Palestiniens ont besoin d'un permis
pour sortir de Gaza donc par exemple
pour un palestinien de Gaza de se rendre
à Jérusalem à 90 km à vol d'oiseau ça
prend un permis d'Israël du kogat et
souvent ils réussissent pas à l'avoir ou
ça peut prendre des mois et des mois
donc si par exemple une femme
palestinienne a besoin de soins de santé
pour soigner un cancer du sein à
Jérusalem est elle va probablement
mourir de son cancer du sein donc vous
donner une petite idée et Jérusalem Est
c'est la partie occupée par Israël de
Jérusalem qui est connectée à la S
Jordanie dont parlait Laurence et donc
tout ce territoire là est collé à la
Jordanie les gens circulent un peu plus
librement mais il y a quand même des
checkpoints et pour les Palestiniens de
la S Jordanie ça prend aussi des permis
pour rentrer en Israël donc tout ça pour
dire que dans le territoire qu'on
appelle la sis Jordanie il y a un
gouvernement qu'on appelle l'Autorité
palestinienne dont le parti au pouvoir
politique s'appelle le fata et il y a
pas eu d'élection depuis bon plus d'une
dizaine d'années presque 15 pour plein
de raisons dans lesquelles on pourrait
aller moi je dirais aussi politiquement
parce que c'est très dangereux en ce
moment s'il y a une élection c'est très
possible que la mass gagne ok fait même
pour la stabilité internationale c'est
oui il y a pas d'élection mais aussi le
fatal ce parti politique là qui est au
pouvoir il est pas particulièrement
populaire euh donc et dans la bande de
Gaza c'est le Hamas qui est au pouvoir
qui a bon au dire du Hamas une aile
politique et une aile militaire si on
veut ou tu le groupe terroriste sauf que
pour beaucoup de pays comme le Canada
peu importe tout tout est est listé sur
le le le Code canadien comme le Hamas
etgal entité terroriste beaucoup de bon
de de de de pays ne font pas la
différence entre une soi-disant aile
politique et une aile militaire ça ça
tient pour d'autres groupes pas
similaires mais disons euh euh qui
existent dans la région euh comme le là
par exemple au Liban ouais quand on dit
le le excusez le le Hamas est au pouvoir
c'est un pouvoir pris de force c'est pas
un pouvoir démocratique non voilà donc
le Hamas est né en
1987 dans la foulée de la première
entifada donc le soulèvement des
Palestiniens la guerre des pierres et
has c'est un acronyme en arabe ça veut
dire mouvement de résistance islamique
c'est un mouvement qui est issu des
Frères musulmans qui était auparavant au
pouvoir entre autres en Égypte et donc
le Hamas il y a eu des élections
élection législative dans dans les
territoires palestiniens et le Hamas a
été élu en 2006 et çaen est suivi une
guerre fratcide avec le FATAD de
marmouabbas sont en guerre les deux
partis politiques exactement le FATAD de
marmoudabbas qui est le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne en sjordanie
entre autres qui contrôle davantage la
sjordanie qui gouverne la sjordanie et
donc ils ont pris le pouvoir en 2007 et
c'est à ce moment-là qu'Israël a imposé
son blocus sur la bande de GRE donc
c'est au moment où est-ce que le Hamas a
pris le pouvoir que ce blocus là a été
mis en place pu c'était une réaction à
cette à ce cette prise de pouvoir là oui
exactement parce que le Hamas est
considéré comme un groupe terroriste par
Israël parce que le Hamas a fait
beaucoup d'attentats terroristes en
guerre formellement avec Israël durant
la seconde encifada les bus qui
sautaient à telavive c'était souvent le
Hamas et donc effectivement le Hamas se
présente comme un mouvement qui a une
aile politique et une aile militaire
donc les brigades alcassam on en entend
beaucoup parler ces jours-ci euh et donc
c'est un mouvement qui est au pouvoir
depuis ce temps-là donc ça fait quoi une
quinzaine d'années maintenant chose qu'
c'est Jordanie pas d'élection ouaisouis
voilà et euh est-ce qu'il y une branche
du Hamas aussi en sjordanie en fait ou
est-ce que c'est c'est lié ouais c'est
lié puis un chapitre aussi en S Jordanie
avec un leader en syjordanie et on a vu
dans les dernières années que le Hamas
était de plus en plus populaire en
syjordanie devant le vide politique
laissé par marmou Abbas qui euh gouverne
sans élection et qui est accusé par les
Palestiniens de collaborer je le mets
entre guillemets avec Israël notamment
tout ce qui est la coordination
sécuritaire euh entre Israël donc
l'armée israélienne et les forces de
sécurité palestinienne et ça on lui
reproche souvent et on l'accuse aussi
d'inaction de ne pas euh se lever
suffisamment devant Israël pour la cause
palestinienne donc sa légitimité un
leader assez vieillissant là qui est pas
très dynamique politiquement ENF que le
fata le fata est un peu moribon mais
l'alternative est aussi effrayantem puis
d'utes groupes terrorist Grou viol
leihad islamique qui aussi attaque
Israël donc il a une multiplicité
d'acteurs qui sont pas toujours des
acteurs intéressé à la démocratie là et
le le Hamas est perçu comment par les
Palestiniens ça c'est une question hyper
délicate là je pense que parce que c'est
sûement plu je pense que je va juste
mettre je veux juste mettre une
parenthèse devant ça
oui en ce moment une des c'est un groupe
qui terroriste qui a fait des horreurs
ok ça c'est laurencech la porte qui
parle puis c'est sûr que mais il y a
beaucoup de gens en ce moment
qui dès qu'il parle de la situation à
Gaza se font poser la question la
première
question s'ils sont dans la bande de
Gaza ou s'ils sont Palestiniens ou s'ils
sont d'origine arabe est-ce que vous
condamner le has comme première question
puis c'est sûr que la vaste majorité des
civils partout dans le monde et ça je le
crois condamne à violence ok mais il y a
il faut je pense que je veux juste
soulever une question par rapport à
euh il y a puis je dis pas que vous
faites ça là mais j'ai juste envie d'en
parler parce que j'ai entendu on entend
beaucoup cette question là de ces
temps-ci c'est un peu comme
euh je me rappelle après 911 là après le
11 septembre beaucoup de mes amis moi
j'étudié aux États-Unis beaucoup de mes
amis musulmanes se faisait se faisait
dire est-ce que c'est quoi ta position
par rapport au terrorisme juste parce
qu'elle c'est pas la même chose ok je
fais des des grandes comparaisons elle
se faisait demander ça d'emblé alors que
évidemment je pense que la plupart des
civils tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est
vivre en paix puis être en sécurité mais
euh donc je pense que Sabrina connaît
beaucoup de gens dans la bande de gazet
pour mieux répondre mais c'est aussi une
une question très difficile à poser à
des gens parce que c'est des gens qui
sont dans une grande insécurité qu'ils
ont pas de pouvoir politique autre que
la masse qui qui même s'il déteste la
masse ça peut être dangereux de le dire
publiquement tout le Mondi je peux aller
sur François leg avec une assez grande
une espèce d'tau politique d'un côté
tout le monde se fait demander de de le
critiquer il y a pas d'alternative
politique c'est évidemment un groupe
cruel et terroriste mais d'un autre côté
euh c'est des gens dangereux aussi il
faut juste comme voir le contexte de ça
quand on entend cette question là c'est
compliqué aussi pour les gens qui
habitent là-bas ouis c'est compliqué
pour eux parce que comme tu l'as dit
Laurence ils peuvent ils peuvent pas le
dire publiquement qu'ils sont en
désaccord avec le Hamas parce qu'ils
pourraient risquer leur vie et un gazaé
avec qui je travaillais dans les
dernières années qui est sur place avec
qui je suis en contact régulièrement sur
WhatsApp donc je vais taire l'identité
évidemment pour sa sécurité tout à fait
m'a dit je lui ai posé un peu la
question comment tu vois ça comment
c'est quoi ton sentiment par rapport au
Hamas puis il m'a
répondu évidemment que je déteste le
Hamas mais il me le dit en chant au cas
où quelqu'un nous écoute au au cas où
quelqu'un l'entend même dans sa propre
maison mais il dit par
contre évidemment qu'il ne célébrait pas
du tout les attaques atroces qui ont été
commises par le Hamas en Israël ça c'est
évident au plan humain pas du tout mais
il m'a dit pour une fois qu'un groupe se
lève pour dénoncer l'occupation
israélienne dénoncer le locus enfin un
groupe
politique se tient debout devant Israël
ça je ne peux pas condamner ça donc
c'est un peu le sentiment vous voyez un
petit peu la nuance où je la mets c'est
c'est je dis que c'est délicat parce que
on pose beaucoup cette question là au
Gazaoui je l'entends souvent à la télé
et tout je sais pas si c'est au Gazaoui
de répondre à à cette question là ils
sont en ce moment dans une situation
atroce eu aussi vivent sous les
bombardement ils ont pas à à justifier
tout ce que laamass a fait parce
qu'effectivement ça été vendu là à Mass
aussi comme un mouvement politique bien
qu'il y a une branche armée puis que le
Canada fasse pas de distinction entre
les deux c'est
aussi le mouvement qui qui gouvernait la
bande de Gaza donc la fonction publique
à Gaza ben c'était géré par le Hamas
donc c'est c'est difficile pour ces
gens-là parce que c'est ça fait partie
aussi de leur quotidien et de leur vie
donc donc il y a beaucoup ce sentiment
là chez les Palestiniens et ils diront
pas publiquement non plus qu'ils sont
pas d'accord avec ce qui s'est passé
avec cette attaque là du has par parce
qu'ils ont peur que ça ait l'air comme
s'il tournait le dos à la cause
palestinienne h même ce serait pas le
cas de dénoncer les les attaques du amas
mais il y a ce sentiment là qui est très
fort chez eux donc ils vont se se
réserver de de répondre à ce genre de
question là ou ouais tout à fait tu sais
nous tu sais nous on peut le dire c'est
un groupe terroriste c'est un groupe
violent c'est des tu sais je veux dire
c'est une abomination qu'un peuple est à
vivre sous sous ce type de régime là
OK puis après ça ben tu on se demande
qu'est-ce que la communauté
internationale aurait pu faire au cours
des dernières décennies pour qu'il y ait
des alternatives politiques à ça on est
dans cette espèce de de on est pris dans
un coin là où est-ce que les deux les
deux blocs politiques sont en guerre il
y en a un qui est qui est pas légitime
puis on a plein de civiles qui sont
juste mises en
danger ben par les bombardements parce
que se fait fait que je pense que en ce
moment les civils la gassa ce qu'il
veulent c'est survivre là tout à fait
qui vont vous répondre aussi c'est
qu'effectivement ils sont ils sont
victimes bien sûr du du Hamas la façon
de gouverner du Hamas mais qu's sont
aussi victimes euh de la situation du
statut quo politique ils sont victimes
de l'occupation depuis 67 et ils sont
victimes des conséquences du blocus là
il y a un blocus total en ce moment sur
la bande de Gaza mais il y avait déjà un
blocus depuis 2007 donc des Palestiniens
2,3 millions de personnes qui peuvent
difficilement vivre à Gaza en raison de
toute cette situation politique là donc
le blocus quand quand on parle du blocus
c'est c'est quoi exactement dans le fond
c'est les VI sont coupés complètement
ben non en fait c'est qu'Israël contrôle
tout ce qui entre et sort de la bande de
Gaza donc les biens et les personnes et
il y a toute une liste là on appelle ça
Dual Use donc toute une liste de bien
qui pourrait être utilisé par exemple à
des fins militaires pour le Hamas qui ne
peuvent pas entrer à Gaza et donc
évidemment ça étouffe économiquement la
bande de Gaza et et ça a des
conséquences graves pour pour les gens
aussi parce que vous avez une population
Gazaoui qui est hyper jeune il y a la
moitié des gazaou qui ont moins de 18
ans et donc qui par exemple n'ont jamais
voté pour le amas là je vous le rappelle
et qui par exemple veulent étudier dans
une université américaine parce qu'ils
ont une super bourse pour s'y rendre
mais pourront jamais avoir le permis
pour sortir parce que tout est contrôlé
c'est la même chose du côté de l'Égypte
ça prend aussi un permis pour sortir du
côté de Rafa c'est un permis qui est
difficile à obtenir donc non seulement
pour un Palestiniens aller par exemple à
Jérusalem c'est extrêmement difficile
mais d'aller n'importe où c'est extrê
tout court cetteand TER les option sont
difficiles les deux côtés mais sont
beaucoup plus difficiles même à Gaza
quand
c'estané on peut être palestinien puis
avoir une autre une deuxième nationalité
soit d'un pays du monde arabe ou du
Canada donc c'est pas exclusif mais si
on est que palestinien parenthèse puis
qu'on est à Gaza là c'est la situation
la plus compliquée non c'est c'est
compliqué là c'est fermé on la surnomme
la prison à ciel ouvert c'est pas pour
rien la S Jordanie vous circuler à peu
près librement mais Gaza pour être déjà
entré vous passez trois checkpoints ça
vous prend des permis partout vous
marchez à travers un espèce de terminal
qui s'appelle RS qui a l'air d'un
terminal d'aéroport puis vous marchez
pendant plusieurs MRE dans un truc de
barbelé très très long il y a toute une
zone tampon aussi que vous traversez
donc non c'est vraiment les les gens
sont sont enfermé quand même à Gaza faut
le dire mettre ça en perspective sachant
à quel point c'est un espace hyper
militarisé et sécurisé c'est aussi ça
qui a choqué surpris à la sur surtout
les citoyens d'Israël mais aussi la
communauté internationale de savoir que
la masse a pu passer à travers tout
cette espèce de de système là de
sécurité qui est qui est étanche parmi
les meilleurs au monde apparemment mais
là de de toute évidence cette réputation
là d'Israël d'être le maître de la
sécurité tout ça éclaté en en morceau là
c'est surtout une réputation face à son
peuple où est-ce que c'est c'est fragile
en ce moment mais parlons-en visouis
fait j'allais aller là est-ce qu'on a
senti une escalade dans le la tenstion
dans l'ambiance dans les dernières
derniers mois mettons ou
C complètement inattendu je remettons en
en situation là vous voulez dire sur le
point de vue en Israël politiquement ou
dans la bande de Gaza les tensions entre
Hamas et Israël est-ce queil y a eu une
escalade avant les guerres précédentes
on voyait toujours des événements qui
montaient tranquillement comme en 2021
on sentait il y avait des tensions sur
les plan des mosquées on sentait avit
exactement et là on sentait que ça
montait ça montait puis on s'attendait à
ce qu'il y a une explosion une escalade
ou une guerre dans ce cas-ci on parle
d'une attaque surprise parce qu'il y a
pas eu ça avant avant PL calme il y
avait une crise politique mais qui ne
touchait pas tant la question
palestinienne à Israël il y a eu des
manifestations monstre parce que bon
c'est combien de fois que netaniaou a
été au pouvoir 6 7 B ça fait ça non mais
qui est revenu il faut tu sais faut
connaître que s'il y a quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse à la science politique ok
Israël
c'est le phénomène de science politique
le plus intéressant parce que c'est la
démocratie la plus directe qui existe ok
peu importe les conversations que nous
nous avons au Québec ou au Canada il y a
des conversation encore plus diversifié
encore plus de débats à l'intérieur de
l'État d'Israël parce que y a énormément
de diversité politique et euh étant
donné que c'est un système proportionnel
disons je veux dire parfait mais
parfaitement direct euh il y a une
multiplicité de partis dès qu'on a le le
le la barre pour pouvoir être représenté
au Parlement est très basse ok alors on
pourrait s'imaginer de d'un d'un d'un
certain point de vue c'est intéressant
parce que ça permet vraiment une
diversité politique très très grande
avant que netaniao il a été sorti du
pouvoir un moment puis il y avait une
autre coalition politique qui était là
avant et CIT un petit peu la coalition
que tout ce qu'il avait en commun c'est
qu'il voulait pas que nthaniao soit au
pouvoir on avait imaginez-vous un groupe
où est-ce que le leader était avant
associé au Frères musulmans alors un un
citoyen d'Israël d'origine arabe parce
qu'il y en a hein euh des gens d'origine
arabe qui euh sont des citoyens d'Israël
il y en a pas mal ok qui sont qui sont
devenus des citoyens d'Israël qui lui
idéologi quement on l'associe au Frères
musulmans qui était dans une coalition
avec un un parti qui était pro
colonisation donc vraiment des gens de
la droit très très religieux qui veulent
prendre des teres en sis-jordanie pour y
retourner donc pour prendre des petites
parti dans ces territoires là qui
devrait être négocié éventuellement mais
qui l'ont le sont toujours pas alors en
attendant ils établissent des ce qu'on
appelle des colonies ces gens-là qu'on
pourrait pas s'imaginer politiquement
plus opposés étaient dans une coalition
ensemble mais c'est ça qui est
complètement fascinant pour les
politologues en Israël mais la coalition
qui est revenue le plus récemment
l'année passée c'était une coalition
avec netaniaou à sa tête mais on est-ce
qu'il y avait énormément mais maintenant
les coalitions pour pour se former elles
ont besoin de souvent ils doivent aller
ramasser plein de petits partis OK puis
souvent des petits partis à la marge et
dans le cas de netanahou surtout des
partis à droite procolonisation très
religieux ok donc dans cette nouvelle
coalition là euh il y avait avait
beaucoup de réformes qui avaient été
promis par netaniaou dans la coalition
dont ce qui disait des réformes du
système judiciaire le système judiciaire
ok de d'Israël est très indépendant en
fait comme système politique le modèle
qui est le blueprint est très très
intéressant et lui voulait un peu
enlever l'indépendance au système
judiciaire alors il y avait eu des
manifestations monstres des citoyens
d'Israël qui s'opposaient à ça alors la
trame politique de ce qui se passait en
Israël là jusqu'au mois d'août c'était
ces manifestationsl du de toute cette
diversité politique là qui disait à o
arrête de détruire notre système
judiciaire puis on se alors on a pas vu
l'escalade c'était vraiment surprise et
d'un autre il y a des gens des
observateurs d'Israël qui se disent
est-ce que c'est justement parce que le
le gouvernement était pris dans ce ce
truc politique là que ça a été ils ont
qu'ils ont perdu le fil un peu de ce qui
se passait effectivement ça ça fait
partie du contexte et du côté de la
sjordanie donc dans les territoires
palestinien on parle beaucoup d'une
attaque surprise du has mais il y avait
quand même des tensions de plus en plus
grande depuis au moins un an et demi
donc des raides de l'armée israélienne
dans des camps de réfugiés palestiniens
de la S Jordanie il y en avait de plus
en plus et il y avait des des morts des
Palestiniens tués par l'armée
israélienne il y avait aussi des
attaques de Palestiniens sur les forces
de l'ordre israélienne chaque jour
chaque semaine et ça vraiment ça montait
on le sentait il y avait un grand
soutien donc entre autres qui montait
pour le Hamas en S Jordanie et on parle
beaucoup d'une attaque surprise mais en
même temps si on va un petit peu plus
loin dans le temps là au cours des
dernières années le Hamas perdait un peu
de terrain au profit du Djihad islamique
à Gaza puis on l' vu parce que les
dernières escalades avec Israël c'était
souvent le le Djihad islamique qui par
deux groupes violents qui c'est un pe le
petit frère du du Hamas finalement qui
ils ont les mêmes les mêmes visés les
mêmes idéos et donc ils étaient souvent
ben les instigateurs des des escalades
et il y avait de plus en plus d'appuis
pour le Djihad islamique et donc le
Hamas dans les dernières années
c'est'est demandé comment on va faire
pour garder ses soutiens là à Gaza donc
il y a ça et il y a aussi ils ont essayé
les dirigeants politiques du Hamas de se
positionner comme un acteur pacifique et
là je le mets en très très gros
guillemets ok on s'entend en organisant
ce qu'on appelle la marche du retour
donc en
2018-2019 il y a des milliers de
Palestiniens qui sont allés manifester à
la ligne de démarcation entre Israël et
Gaza tous les vendredi pendant ça a duré
plus d'un an mais c'est ça les
manifestations la barrière hein
exactement ça s'appelait la marche du
retour puis il y avait deux objectifs
donc c'était de dénoncer le blocus mais
c'était aussi de réclamer le droit au
retour des réfugiés et quand on allait
sur place on voyait des grosses photos
de Gandi des grosses photos de Nelson
Mandela donc là la amas à ce moment-là
voulait se positionner comme un
mouvement pacifique en tout cas c'était
son intention de c pas perçu comme ça
par quiconque mais c'était perçu comme
ça de l'extérieur de Gaza de l'extérieur
de Gaza non mais à Gaza même un peu
quand même parce que pour avoir couvert
largement ces manifestations là il y
avait très peu de violence du côté de
Gaza dans le sens où h il y avait des
parents des grands-mères des
grands-pères des enfants qui allaient
manifester avec des drapeau Palestiniens
bien sûr il y avait des jeunes
Palestiniens qui allaient lancé des
pierres en direction des soldats qui eux
étaient postés le long de de la
frontière donc il y avait des tireurs
d'élite qui tiraent à bal réel de
l'autre côté il y a eu quelques
tentatives d'infiltration mais c'était
très mineur si on compare à la l'ampleur
de ce mouvement là qui était du jamais
vu quand même du côté de Gaza et donc ça
a duré pendant
et il y a plusieurs palestiniens qui ont
été ben tués premièrement mais aussi
handicapés parce que ça a été démontré
par les ONG qu'on visait les les les les
tireurs deé Lite israélien visaient
principalement les genoux et les hanches
donc les gens mouraient pas donc dans
les bilans c'était moins dramatique si
on veut mais il y a toute une génération
de Palestiniens qui qui ont subi les
conséquences de ça et donc un an plus
tard les les Palestiniens ont dit un
instant ça nous a donné quoi nous
d'aller au front comme ça de se faire
tirer dessus et ils ont essayé de se
soulever contre le Hamas et le Hamas tir
à bal réel dans les manifestation à
l'intérieur de la de la bande de Gaza
ont sur leur propre sur leur propre sur
les Palestiniens sur leur propre peuple
donc donc quand je vous dis qu'ils sont
ils peuvent difficilement s'exprimer
c'est vrai aussi et après bon c ce
mouvement là est mort et dans les années
suivantes il y il y a rien d'autres qui
qui s'est passé puis le Jihade islamique
était beaucoup plus populaire et bon et
donc dans ce contexte là le Hamas était
aussi perçu comme un peu le gestionnaire
de la bande de Gaza qui négociait
parfois avec Israël des cesser le feu et
donc je crois qu'il a ressenti le besoin
le mouvement de changer sa casquette
d'enlever sa casquette de
gestiontionnaire d'interlocuteurs
politique avec Israël pour la casquette
de mouvement de résistance pour aller
chercher davantage d'appuis donc c'estis
attaque surprise oui parce que pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi pas il y a 2
semaines pourquoi pas dans 2 mois mais
est-ce qu'elle surprenante h non
maintenant est-ce qu'elle est inédite
dans son ampleur la coordination oui ça
ça a surpris tout le monde les
Israëliens en premier évidemment donc
c'est ça son objectif majeur Majeur au
avec cette attaque là c'est de
réaffirmer un peu sa position par
rapport à Israël et par rapport à son
propre peuple c'estis en même temps nous
on peut essayer de représenter leur
discours voir comment il se projette
mais on connait pas véellement la
psychoanalyse de comment on pense que
c'est justifié d'égorger des des enfants
c'est-à-dire que on peut on peut tout
parce que parce que cette analyse
politique là moi je la je la maîtrise
pas parce que
je auère tu sais la violence politique
on peut analyser le discours à travers
laquelle ils essayent de la justifier
ouais
euh mais après ça on a beaucoup de
limite en terme dans notre analyse
sur est-ce que ça peut atteindre comme
pourquoi aller si loin pourquoi être si
cruel on n pas de réponse puis aussi
pourquoi on il y a aussi beaucoup de
limite sur comment c'est perçu justement
par la population locale mais parce que
ça à quoi on a accès c'est très limité
il y a beaucoup de censure puis il y a
beaucoup de propagande du amasit que des
deux côtés la propagande oui oui je sais
mais sur sur le discours ouais mais sur
le discours du amas je peux juste pe pas
regarder d'autres chose que eux-mêmes
fait que ça va il y a la en ce moment là
le problème de la désinformation de la
propagande l'accès sur ce conflitl c'est
comme énorme donc c'est dur de dire
c'était quoi leur objectif avec cette
attaque là mais tu sais on peut dire on
peut dire c'est quoi leur leurs
objectifs politiques ils ont toujours
dit qu'ils étaient en guerre ils veulent
défendre il ils disent être justement
les défendeurs de la résistance et
cetera mais je veux juste pas je veux
pas que ça soit perçu comme que quoi que
ce soit soit justifiable dans leur
violence politique un discours puis
après ça il y a tout le reste de
évidemment qu'on ne justifie pas en vous
racontant tout le contexte on ne
justifie pas du tout la violence inouie
des attaques qui ont été commises contre
les Israéliens là ça faut que ce soit
clair parce que c'est tellement polarisé
la question en ce moment que c'est un
terrain hyper glissant tout ce qu'on dit
peut être interprété donc jamais rien ne
justifie d'attaquer des civils h dans
une guerre tout à fait qu' soit
israélien ou palestinien rien ne
justifie que des gens comme ça souffrent
en ce moment autant les Israéliens que
les Palestiniens ça c'est sûr donc
tenons-nousant au fait en fait qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé euh c'est journé là en
fait ben tôt le matin il y a des
centaines voir des milliers il y avait
le chiffre de 4500 qui circulaient
combattant du amas et du Djihad
islamique qui ont lancé leur attaque
coordonnée donc le matin du 7 octobre
2023 d'abord ils ont lancé des drones
pour détruire les caméras de
surveillance tout au long de la bande de
gazol de la quarantaine de kilomètres et
puis ensuite ils ont ils se sont
attaqués à des bases militaires et des
checkpoints donc le checkpoint des entre
autres et à d'autres endroits à 29
endroits du mur qui sépare les deux
territoires ben le mur a des sections en
béton mais aussi des sections en double
barbelé si vous voulez il y a eu 29
brèches selon ce qui a été rapporté par
les médias israéliens entre autres donc
ils sont entrés par là et au même moment
il y avait aussi plusieurs parapantes ou
deltalan qui ont survolé le mur et du
côté de la mer il y a aussi des des
incursions du côté de la mer et donc ils
sont allés partout dans dans les kibuts
les mochaves les les villes villages du
sud d'Israël dans un festival qui avait
eu lieu toute la nuit là-bas là
exactement dans le désert où il y avait
un festival donc tout tout ce qui est
l'enveloppe de Gaza donc tout ce qui se
trouve autour de la bande de Gaza et
donc ils sont allés là-bas ils se sont
ils ont attaqué donc des policiers des
militaires mais aussi des civils des
femmes des enfants des hommes eu ça a
duré pendant des heures et c'est ce qui
est surprenant c'est le manque de
réaction des autorités israéliennes h
tout est tellement contrôlé il y a
tellement de surveillance euh donc ça ça
a été une des questions des premières
questions qui euh qui a surgi comme où
où où vous êtes là et les gens qui se
barricadaient puis au même moment il y a
aussi un barrage de de roquettes en
provenance de Gaza donc et ils ont lancé
des roquettes très très loin dans le
territoire pour faire diversion donc
pendant tout ce moment-là il y avait
tellement pour les les autorités
israéliennes de choses à gérer que
c'était vraiment le chaos et le chaos a
duré pendant euh 36h et plus avant que
les autorités israéliennes ou les forces
de l'ordre puissent réussir à contrôler
ce qui se passait et donc dans certains
villages ben tout le monde a été
massacré là et je vous éparne les
détails c'est des images horribles euh
les les atrocités qui ont été commises
sont sont difficilement euh euh on peut
difficilement parler là c'est
imaginez-vous le pire ben c'est ce qui
s'est passé et euh et les gens ils ont
pris des otages effectivement donc ils
ont tué 1400 israéliens ou des des
binationaux et des étrangers et ensuite
ils ont pris en otage et ça aussi
c'était inédit là entre 200 250
personnes qu'ils ont ramené euh dans la
bande de Gaza donc ça c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans un premier temps dans le sud
d'Israël et ils ont réussi à juste
revenir non dans la bande de Gaza
certains sont revenus mais plusieurs ont
été tués sur le territoire donc à un
certain point ça c'est pas une
information vérifier mais Israël a dit
euh avoir retrouvé les corps de 1500
combattants du amass et du islamique je
sais pas si c'est un chiffre qui qui est
exact mais donc les forces de l'ordre
ont fini par arriver et ces gens-là ont
été tués il y a aussi des des civils qui
sont armés donc il y a certains kibuts
qui se sont défendus eux-mêmes ou qui
ont essayé eu mais voilà donc ça a pris
vraiment tout le monde par surprise puis
il y avait des gens dans leur maison qui
étaient barricadés puis qui qui disaient
mais mais mais où êtes-vous là où où
sont où est la police où sont nos
soldats comment comment ça on a pas de
nouvell et on est encore barricadé 36 he
plus tard dans nos maisons àdod
àkelonerot c'est des grosses villes
israéliennes quand même qui sont situées
très très près de la bande de Gaza puis
il y a certains kibbots ou dont un ou
moi je suis allé faire des reportages il
y a quelques années le Kibo est collé
sur le mur c'estàdire que quand il y a
des manifes à Gaza de l'autre côté du
mur on sent la fumée des pneus qui
brûlent on entend les gens scander des
slogans et ce kibots là a été en partie
épargné parce qu'il y a des gens qui
l'ont défendu qui était armé on souvent
des gardiens armés dans ces petits
kibuts là eu et la dame que j'avais
rencontré ben je je lui ai parlé puis je
lui demandé bon avez-vous survécu tu
sais c'est pas drôle de devoir poser ces
questionsl à des gens on est on est mal
de de de leur écrire ça mais mais
avez-vous survécu oui ok comment
allez-vous là bon mais mais dans
plusieurs cas 1400 civils et policiers
militair su c'est quand même il encore
des petits enfants qui sont t dans la
bande de gaz et tout ça là j'écoutais
euh
une entreview au New York Times de la
famille de quelqu'un qui à Gaza puis
elle a fait un discours à l'ONU là hier
je pense et donc ça ça vient changer
tout le rapport de force aussi du has
d'avoir ces otages là là c'était très
stratégique de de de faire ça c'est une
façon pour laamass de négocier des
choses et c'est ce qui rend aussi
beaucoup plus compliqué l'opération
terrestre d'Israël dans la bande de Gaza
parce que est-ce qu'on protège les
otages est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on choisit
de bombarder massivement et de faire une
opération terrestre qui à ce que nos
otages soient tués dans dans cette
opération là c'est c'est quand même
assez délicat donc c'est c'est un
terrain miné là pour pour les Israéliens
ça a été quoi justement après le chaos
initial puis un peu le désorganisation
tout ça ça étit quoi la réponse de de de
de l'armée israélienne puis du
gouvernement israélien ces événement là
ben immédiatement ils ont bombardé la
bande de Gaza ça c'est sûr ils ont
appelé à leur droit de se défendre
contre le Hamas qui qualifie de
terroriste et donc et mais mais les
Israéliens eux-mêmes moi c'est ce que je
trouve ce que je trouve intéressant de
d'analyser c'est c'est que pour eux là
c'était un c'est le ça a été le jour le
plus meurtrier depuis l'Holocauste donc
là on est venu toucher un traumatisme
collectif qui est vraiment important
donc pour les Israéliens ça a été le le
premier sentiment évidemment la la
douleur là et après la douleur la colère
contre le Hamas bien sûr contre aussi
leur propre gouvernement qui n'a pas
réussi à à les défendre parce que l'État
d'Israël a été créé entre autres pour ça
et et donc la colère contre leur
gouvernement et contre le manque de
réaction devant cette cette opération
des combattants du Hamas et et donc et
donc il a ça et ils ont appelé à une
réponse très très forte à Gaza à la
hauteur de leur douleur finalement et
c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans la
bande de gazar puis peut-être que je
peux tu sais ce qui est intéressant
quand qu' on s'intéresse à cette région
là c'est que on est ici puis on entend
le discours du gouvernement israélien
puis on entend le discours moins mais en
tout cas si on cherche les information
on le voit le discours du has puis j'ai
parlé de la SA de la diversité qui
existe dans les opinions de plus de 2
millions 2 millions de personnes dans la
bande de Gaza c'est évident la diversité
politique qui existe en Israël mais ce
qui paraît par particulièrement cruel
puis ma collègue avec qui j'anime mon
balado leura Julie per à la presse elle
a écrit au début là un article sur une
le le profil d'une femme en particulier
donc j'ai oublié le le nom là mais je je
vais vous parler un peu de cette
situation là c'est que il faut
comprendre que à la fondation de l'État
d'Israël puis pendant longtemps il y a
quand même eu là maintenant on voit
beaucoup de gouvernement de droite mais
il y avait quand même disons un
mouvement Hipi OK ou bien
cétait en fait cétait presque la norme
pendanttemps en Israël sa moi
j'ai on parle de de quand à peu près
cette période là ben c'était sais des
années des années 40 là quand ça se
formait jusqu'à jusqu'aux années 80 même
là mais accords de SL m mais il y a des
gens là que si vous allez lire les
nouvelles puis il y en a qui se disent
tu sais i'm from the peace camp il y a
des gens qui s'identifient comme des
gens qui veulent la paix avec les
Palestiniens ok la solution à de il y a
tout monde qui croyait fort à ça aussi
en Israël puis c'est c'est quoi une Kib
un kibut c'est une commune donc il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont vécu dans dans
ces communes là qui est un peu c'est
pour ça je dis IPI des années 70 dans
ces modèles de communes là qui qui sont
il y a même des activistes pacifistes ok
qui ces gens-là existent ils sont pas
bien représentés politiquement entre
autres une femme d'origine canadienne
qui qui a été pris en otage et là je
m'excuse parce que son nom m'échappe
mais je vous le donnerai puis on on le
mettra dans le script à quelque part
puis Julie Perro écrit un article sur
elle parce que c'est particulièrement ça
semble particulièrement cruel ironique
mais c'est pas si anecdotique que ça
dans la cruauté de la situation qui
impacte ces gens-là c'est que cette
femme-là elle habitait entre autes dans
un kibbout près de la bande de Gaza ce
que j'en comprends parce que c'était une
activiste pour la paix qui faisait
beaucoup d'action avec la bande de Gaza
à un moment donné il y avait eu un
soldat qui avait été tenu age otage par
la Hamas pendant longtemps à Gaza elle
elle avait même contribué à la
négociation Chalit voilà elle avait
contribué à la négociation euh de de ce
soldat parce qu'elle avait des relations
à Gaza qui étaient utiles pour l'armée
israélienne cette femme-là a été pris en
otage parce qu'elle était dans un kibot
parce qu'elle était là parce que elle
est activiste pour la paix et ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant c'est que
oui le gouvernement d'Israël a dit
écoute on va on va aller au plus fort
euh tout faire mais ce qu'on entend
beaucoup en ce moment puis ça ça me
touche particulièrement c'est des
familles des otages qui disent pas au
nom de ma mère pas au nom de ma sœur
j'ai dit faut pas aller tuer des civils
pas utiliser comme excuse pour le faire
et puis moi il y avait une entrevue un
entretien entre autres avec le fils de
cette femme-là qui qui donnait des
entrevues qui disait la dernière chose
que ma mère veut là elle est prise en
otage elle est entourée de gens qui on
qui auront été tués par le mass et que
il y a des civils qui meurent à cause de
à cause de tout ça tu sais fait que
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
oui ce discours là politique il est
dominant par le gouvernement mais il y a
il y a toute cette complexité là aussiou
tout à fait tout à fait est-ce que tu
penses que c'est une minorité par contre
en Israël en ce moment de gens qui ont
ce discours là je sais pas je sais pas
parce que mais je pense
que la gauche
elle existe encore mais c'est juste que
dans la les coalitions puis je pense que
ce qu'on a vu euh ce tu sais je ve ce
qu'on a vu dans les manifestations cet
été c'est que c'est une société de
contestation aussi il y a un ministre
qui qui est venu faire un tour d'un
hôpital après le massacre puis s'est
fait sortir de force de l'hôpital parce
que personne ne voulait voir quelqu'un
du gouvernement donc moi je veux juste
qu'on s'assure que c'est beaucoup plus
facile de représenter les choses blancs
et noires mais quand on s'intéresse à à
ces sociétésl il y a tu sais je veux
dire au bout de la ligne que ça soit des
Palestiniens des Israéliens des
israéliens d'origine arabe des arabos
Isra je sais pas comment chaque personne
Palestiniens d'Israël en fait c'est des
gens qui sont restés là après 48 là euh
il y a beaucoup il y a encore des gens
qui qui croient à la paix puis tout ça
ils sont aussi horrifiés que nous que
par ce qui se passe en est-ce qu' ont
été
très vocal et entendu les Israéliens de
gauche pour la paix depuis le depuis les
événement ou ou plutôt ils se
font mais moi je j'entends les familles
des otages là entre autes parce que ces
gens-là on ont accès à aux médias puis
ils sont très médiatisés ouais c'est ça
euh mais bon c'est juste je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens en Israël qui sont
critiques aussi de ce qui se passe ouais
moi de ce que je perçois et j'ai perçu
dans les dernières années c'est
malheureusement un délitement de la
gauche israélienne donc de moins en
moins de gens qui qui sont à
gauche et ça se reflète par un
gouvernement de plus en plus à droite
aussi donc le camp de la paix est plus
qu'il était c'est vrai que ces voixlà ça
prend tellement de courage pour demander
à son gouvernement de ne pas bombarder
Gaza en ce moment parce que c'est pas la
solution à la paix alors que ta propre
mère par exemple est autage ou tu as
perdu des amis dans ces attaques là du
Hamas ça prend un courage énorme pour se
lever et et dire ça à mon avis personnel
j'ai pas de chiffre pour vous mais je
pense que ça reste une minorité en
Israël quand mêmeouais juste pour la
petite anecdote en fait là moi je j'ai
dit la musique jazz là bref puis il y a
beaucoup des meilleurs musiciens de jazz
à New York qui sont d'origine
israélienne je sais pas c'est quoi la
raison mais peut-être qu'il on un
programme très fort en musique là-bas
juif d'origine juive d'origine juive
ouais c'est ça
puis j'en suis beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux donc tu sais après les
événements je je je voyais passer la
réaction de certains ou ben ou j'étais
curieux en fait de voir comment ces
gensl vont réagir tu sais des sais
beaucoup des gens justement d'origine
israélienne qui qui habitent plus puis
qui Pr des artistes donc peut-être de
tendance plus de gauche que que d'autres
puis justement beaucoup se prononçaient
pas puis il y en a un qui s'est prononcé
puis que son tu sais il a juste écrit
sur
Instagram la paix avant tout Saou
quelque chose comme ça tu sais juste
comme la paix je pense qu'il y a aussi
la tradition de la musique CLM il y a
beaucoup de musique juives qui viennent
des Balcans de l'exyoslavie de ces
région là qui ont beaucoup
de de lien avec le jazz aussi je pense
qu'il y ça qui peut faire qui pe la
diaspora est beaucoup plus libérale
aussi aux États-Unis notamment à New
York là donc pas mais bref tout ça pour
dire que sous ce post là qui qui qui
semble-t-il je veux dire qui paraît
comme une position non controversée de
juste vouloir la paix tu sais puis
évidemment il y avait beaucoup de
commentaires qui qui qui qui
applaudissaient puis qui saluaient ce ce
prise de position là mais il y avait
aussi beaucoup de commentaires puis en
faisant mes petites en all voir c'est
qui était d'illeurs d' des d'autres
alien qui disait c'est dangereux de de
dire ça puis c'est pas le temps de de de
de faire ce genre de prise de position
là quand que T tout ce qu' demandait
puis tout c'est tout ce qu' souhaitait
c'est la paix quand la paix est devenu
une
position controversé ou dangereuse entre
guillemets on on a un problème h HM ben
tout à fait mais c'est que les gens sont
sont hyper polarisés un peu comme comme
je le disais j'ai l'impression que moi
les autant les Israéliens que les
Palestiniens sont touchés dans leur
traumatisme le plus le plus profond tout
le monde est campé sur ses positions et
maintenant même les gens qui sont pro
palestinien par exemple n'os pas le dire
parce qu'on associe proalestinien à
Hamas alors que c'est un amalgame qui
est hyper dangereux mais même ce terme
pro palestinien c'est-àdire que pour les
camp oui tout à fait mais mais mais mais
donc c'est c'est un amalgame qui est
dangereux parce que le le Hamas n'égale
pas la bande de Gazin non plus il faut
arrêter de faire faire ces amagames là
pu on vient à dum aniser les 2300000
Palestiniens dont la moitié d'enfants
qui vivent à gazar parce qu'on dit on
sous-entend que ils sont tous
terroristes et qu'ils ont tous des
acintances avec la masse donc ouais
c'est hy sens beaucoup de gens aussi
dans mon entourage qui qui ont qui ont
voulu se se justement se prononcer sur
les réseaux sociaux partager de
l'information partager des pétitions
partager des lev de fond tout ça puis
plusieurs m'ont dit tu sais je fais
quelque chose il a quelqu'un qui m'écrit
qui me dit tu devrais pas partager ça
soit c'est pas une information fiable ou
soit tu es ça veut dire que tu supportes
tel groupe ou tel groupe on dirait que
tout le monde marche sur des un
situation là c'est on a comme deux
guares en même temps là on a la Guer sur
le terrain des gens qui la vivent puis
on est en train de vivre après l'Ukraine
probablement la deuxème guerre la plus
médiatisée qui a qui a lieu en même
temps sur des réseaux sociaux puis je
dis pas qu'il faut pas utiliser les
réseaux sociaux c'est comme si si tout
le monde peut s'exprimer a besoin de
s'exprimer mais il y a plein de
dynamique qui se passent en parallèle il
y a comme une guerre des médias une gure
des médias des journalistes qui meurent
ok ça c'est extrêmement grave dans cette
guerre là il y a plein de gens les les
journalistes internationaux ont pas
accès à Gaza alors on sait pas les
sources d'information les gens se
mettent dans des à risque tu sais la
famille je pense d'un reporter d'aljzera
a été complètement tué
hier le nombre de journalistes tués à ce
jour là c'est effrayant alors il y a ça
ensuite puis on sait très bien tous les
problèmes avec nos médias sociaux
d'algorithm de toxicité de bot de
désinformation par que là on est en
train de de de faire de trucs en
parallèle donc c'est sûr que tout tout
ce qui est polarisant devient euh
décuplé devient ouais devient
complètement nourri euh devient encore
plus polarisé par les médias sociaux
alors là ben comme on n'est pas on n'est
pas servi hein par les médias sociaux
dans ce cas-là puis je dis pas il y a
rien d'autre à faire c'est sûr que les
tu sais des gens là comme nous qui on
peut pas attendre que que toutes sortes
dans les médias pour voir ce qui se
passe on a envie de voir les histoires
des gens puis il y a juste les médias
sociaux qui existent pour ça à part les
liens personnels mais on est aussi dans
une espèce de course contre la montre o
est-ce que le New York Time essaie
d'être aussi vite que Twitter fait qu'il
font des mises à jour à toutes les 6
minutes fait qu'on est vraiment dans
cette espèce
d'hypermédiatisation là de la guerre
puis comme des fois on peut tomber dans
un trou en ligne puis c'est difficile
d'en sortir puis on sait pas pourquoi on
se fait servir certains contenus hm hm
euh avant de parler de la roste
israélienne puis euh de où est-ce qu'on
jusqu'à où est-ce qu'on en est
maintenant là
netanahou c'est qui lui puis de
qu'est-ce qu'il veut d'où il vient non
mais genre non mais faisons le même
exercice que que on a fait tantôt pour
le pour la hamass pour bien comprendre
le gouvernement israélien c'est qui lui
puis on a parlé un petit peu des des
coalitions tout à l'heure là mais d'où
il vient c'est quoi son background puis
euh la même question peut-être un petit
peu un petit peu touché que tantôt c'est
quoi la perception des Israéliens aussi
pluriel peut-elle être de leur premier
ministre la politologue
non bibi on l'appelle bibi on l'appelle
le roi bibi même en Israël parce qu'il
est au pouvoir depuis là j'ai pas les
dates en tête mais depuis tellement
longtemps euh il avait perdu sans les
dates exactes on parle plus d'une
décennie plus d'une décennie élu réélu
c'est un as de la politique il est euh
en politique pour l'élicou depuis des
années euh et il est extrêmement
intelligent euh capable de naviguer
là-dedans parle un un excellent anglais
beaucoup de contact côte américain il a
étudié je pense aux États-Unis et donc
il a été il a perdu les élections il y a
quelques années avant de revenir au
pouvoir mais c'est un surtout un homme
politique qui s'accroche au pouvoir et
qui est prêt à tout pour le garder et
lors des dernières élections pour
pouvoir gouverner le pays il y a comme
Laurence l'expliquait a tout ce système
proportionnel en Israël donc il n'a pas
eu le choix de s'allier même si c'était
peut-être pas son premier choix mais à
des partis d'extrême droite eu et des
partis ultra religieux des partis très
sionistes aussi pour rester au pouvoir
donc c'est sa sa base finalement ouais
sa base c'est la droite mais il a du
salié avec l'extrême droiteou pour
rester au pouvoir pour pouvoir gouverner
et donc il était critiqué en fait il est
en procès pour corruption abus de
confiance et tout ça des histoires avec
des des médias israéliens des P de vin
exactement euh et des riches hommes
d'affair et donc il est en danger c'est
une des raisons d'ailleurs pour laquelle
il essaie de changer le le système
judiciaire il veut que la il veut avoir
plus de pouvoir que la Cour suprême en
est moins et donc il était très
fragilisé dans une histoire pas au
États-Unis on dirait tout à fait et donc
là il était très fragilisé dans les
derniers mois parce que il y avait ses
manifestations contre la réforme du du
du système judiciaire on le critiquait
beaucoup et c'est Monsieur on l'appelle
aussi monsieur sécurité là en Israël
parce
que il y avait ce discours sécuritaire
très fort mais en même temps bibi
voulait jamais entrer en guerre voulait
jamais aller en guerre parce que ça peut
être à double tranchant mener une guerre
soit politiquement
vous allez pouvoir récolter plein
d'appuis mais ça se passe mal puis vous
avez beaucoup de pertes humaine côté des
soldats israéliens par exemple ça peut
aussi vous coûter cher politiquement
donc donc voilà le genre de personnage
qu'on a qui qui est au pouvoir
aujourd'hui qui va devoir répondre à pas
mal de questions dans les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois peut-être
sur comment c'est possible de l'avoir
échappé à ce point-là le 7 octobre
dernier il va avoir bien sûr une enquête
puis il va devoir répondre de ça puis on
se demande est-ce que Bibi va survivre
politiquement à cette histoire monsieur
sécurité ouais c'est pas très
sécuritaire ben c'est pas c'est un échec
cuisant ça c'est certain pour la classe
politique mais aussi pour tout
l'appareil sécuritaire israélien il faut
comprendre qu'en Israël l'armée le
service militaire joue un rôle
extrêmement important parce que c'est
obligatoire de faire un service
militaire pour les femmes aussi il y a
une industrie de la technologie très
très avancée qui un peu comme
l'invention de l'internet aux États-Unis
est toujours lié au au secteur de la
sécurité au à l'état militaire si on
veut c'est très rare là que des grandes
technologies ont été développées dans
l'histoire que que ça soit le GPS
Internet et cetera sans un lien souvent
à toutes les tout le financement qui
vient de du système militaire donc le
système militaire israélien est est une
incion très très très importante pour
l'État d'Israël ou très très importante
pour nthaniao aussi mais aussi
économiquement emploie énormément de
monde parce que beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelle le siliconvé Israël ont des
liens très très forts avec tout ce qui
est militaire ou c'est des anciens
militaires qui ont fait carrière puis
qui après sont allés dans le secteur
privé puis quelle est la j'imagine qui
est aussi diverse encore une fois la
perception internationale de Bibi il
a-tu des bonnes relations politiqu ce
est intéressant c'est que un peu comme
les grands
leaders de ce monde qui qui joue de de
mains fortes là il est capable de faire
des rencontres que ça soit avec des je
pense qu'il y avait eu des rencontres
bilatérales récemment avec la Turquie ou
avec l'Inde avec des pays qui ont pas
toujours
été soutenus ou politiquement avec
Israël mais c'est un gars qui est
capable de faire des deal OK puis je
veux dire il est pas vraiment dans dans
le
discours du multilatéralisme tout le
temps puis évidemment tu
sais il y a il y a vraiment un pays
comme le Canada on est des alliés très
important d'Israël mais en même temps
naniaou a été capable pu ça c'était
c'était très très visible avec Obama il
va avoir un discours même si par exemple
Israël dépend énormément du soutien
américain il peut avoir un discours très
dur à l'endroit des leaders politiques
comme Obama par exemple il l' un peu
envers Biden mais c'était très très dur
envers Obama envers les démocrates en
particulier parce qu'il aime pas se
faire quoi dire se faire dire quoi faire
pardon et puis souvent les démocrates
aux États-Unis par rapport au
républicains on dit plutôt fait
attention à la colonisation le droit
international ça ça énerve netanahou
fait que il va il va le dire très
publiquement des choses dures par
rapport au leader américains puis ça
démon ça ça ça ça contribue à son jeu
politique envers la population
israélienne où est-ce qu'il y a l'air de
tu pas de se tenir debout pour même si
on est un petit pays on est capable de
leur dire de nous laisser faire tu sais
h ben ils ont besoin de Benjamin
netanahou de toute façon les pays
occidentx pour notamment les États-Unis
pour asseoir leur place au Moyen-Orient
je veux dire Israël c'est une base
extraordinaire pour les États-Unis donc
ils ont besoin de collaborer de toute
façon avec Israël pour des raisons
stratégiques sécuritaires c'est pas
toujours une relation facile he c'est
pas c'est des alliés proche mais des
fois dans les personnalités il peut y
avoir des tensions mais tu dis à à soir
leur place moyenoriant mais ça veut dire
quoi concrètement c'est quoi l'avantage
des étatunis dans de de cette alliance
là le
plus pense que le monde occidental
ressent tu sais que ça soit l'Europe ou
le Canada ou les États-Unis ressent une
responsabilité grande par rapport à
Israël puis ça tu sais il faut le
comprendre parce que il y a aussi
euh tu sais il y a aussi une une honte
qui est relié à l'holocauste ok euh puis
une honte qui est bien placée
historiquement ok c'est que dans ces
sociétés-là puis même si tu sais le
Canada on a on a pas on était pas
l'Allemagne là on était de l'autre côté
mais quand même il y a des bateaux
remplis de réfugiés juifs qui sont
arrivés aux frontières et qu'on a
renvoyé et ces gensl ont ét renvoyés
dans des camps de concentration fait que
c'est un peu dans dans l'histoire euh on
a tu sais il y a une responsabilité
collective d'avoir laissé faire
l'Holocauste puis dans la construction
du système international d'après deuxè
guerre mondiale dans les années 40 euh
c'était la première grande question du
système multilatéral si on veut
c'est-à-dire que c'était qu'est-ce qu'on
fait après l'holocauste c'est tout ce
qui est la construction du
multilatéralisme des cours
internationales ça c'était beaucoup
autour de cette questionl c'est pas
étonnant tu sais on se demande des fois
c'est quoi unra cette agence pour les
réfugiés palestiniens pourquoi ils vont
pas à l'agence des réfugi normal comme
tout le monde mais c'est parce que la
première agence pour réfugiés qui existe
c'était une agence pour palestinen il y
avait pas de système pour les réfugiés
c'était comme la première crise de
réfugiés euh qui était traité comme
comme problème mme si on veut que le le
nouveau système de l'onus disait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ont créé une agence
juste pour ça puis évidemment ce qu'on
crée pendant 2 minutes reste pendant 100
ans là mais c'estàd que pas 100 ans mais
h existe encore puis si on a été réfugié
palestinien au Liban notre école là est
gérée encore par honra après même si on
est né au Liban puis ma mère est né au
Liban alors ce système là c'est comme
rester et rester en place mais il faut
comprendre que la question de la
créationét israë elle elle est très
importante pour ces pays-là qui ont dû
euh dire oh my god on a laissé toutes
ces gens-là se faire tuer qu'est-ce
qu'on fait il faut tu sais il y a quand
même une responsabilité puis c'est une
des raisons pour laquelle évidemment le
Canada était un des premiers pays à
reconnaître l'état d'Israël parce que
parce qu'il y a une responsabilité
envers envers la communauté juive de
ceux qui ont survécu évidemment ça ça a
été fait de manière sur
entremêlé avec avec plein de de restes
de colonisation au Moyen-Orient dans
cette régionl qui était très forte qui
avait des mandats du qui ça été faite de
manière très très maladroite pour les
Palestiniens qui ont été déplacés et
cetera mais il faut comprendre aussi
comme psychologiquement politiquement
comment les pays occidentaux ont
développé cette relation là avec Israël
aussi c'est pas pour rien je me demande
bien quelle responsabilité collective on
aura peut-être dans 10 15 20 ans 30 ans
par rapport aux Palestiniens dans le
sens où il y a quand même eu un statut
quo depuis des années on pourrait dire
depuis plus de 30 ans si on se réfère
aux accords d'Oslo de 93 mais euh quand
même les Palestiniens payent le prix de
ce jeu politique là aujourd'hui je me
demande comment on va regarder
l'histoire dans quelques années euh
quand on va prendre un petit peu de
recul pu on va se dire ok euh il y a
plusieurs pays occidentaux euh danst le
Canada qui euh ont donné tout un feu
vert au début de CER je voudrais pas
dire ont participé directement mais qui
ont donné le feu vert à Israël à une
campagne de bombardement massif en ce
parle de cette annéel je parle de
maintenant de cette guerre là quel quel
rôle on aura joué la communauté
internationale qui aura très peu retenu
si on veut la colère des Israéliens
parce qu'au départ évidemment on a
condamné fermement et avec raison les
attaques du Hamas mais on n pas appelé à
la retenue ça ça a pris quelques jours
et les premiers appels à la retenue ont
été mou très très mou autant du Canada
que d'autres pays de
l'Occident là on commence à parler d'une
pause et non de C il a tout un débat
sémantique làdessus pause trêve cesser
le feu c'est c'est c'est c'est de la
communication politique mais sais
ultimement il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose là ouais parce qu'en ce
moment les Palestiniens ce qu'il disent
c'est pas un terme que j'endosse mais je
vous partage le discours des
Palestiniens c'est dire ben là nous en
ce moment on vit un génocide là dans le
sens où les les civils sont visés de
façon
indiscriminée c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
il y a des milliers de personnes qui
meurent puis il y en a plein d'autres
sous les décombres donc juste la
question que je me pose dans quelques
années comment on va regarder l'histoire
avec un peu de recul je pense qu'on va
on va avoir de toute part honte de ce
qui s ce qui s'est passé la façon don
sété géré ouais ouais puis à chaque jour
c'est ça le discours politique change
ouais ça a été quoi la suite des
événements mainant qu'on veut faire un
genre de chronologie après les attaques
initiales puis dans la tu sais il y a eu
plusieurs événements m'amené l'Israélien
le gouvernement israélien a dit
on il faut que 2. 2.1 million 2.3
million de de Gazaoui se déplace sais ça
a été quoi en fait là tu sais de de de
ces événments là j aujourd'hui espèce de
timeline ben rapidement on a bombardé
donc la bande de Gaza pour
officiellement éradiquer le Hamas donc
détruire les infrastructures du Hamas
c'est-à-dire les tunnels les dépôts
d'armes les tuer aussi les leaders du
Hamas donc ça c'était pour cette
raison-là officiellement évidemment
qu'il y a des civils qui vivent à Gaza
qui qui on qui sont qui sont morts qui
ont été tués par ces bombesl et
rapidement Israël a a déployé des tanks
des soldats israéliens tout le long de
la frontière avec Gaza c'est pas une
frontière mais la ligne de démarcation
avec Gaza h donc ça ça a été fait et il
y a eu sur le terrain des incursions
terrestres tranquillement on en a fait
il y a déjà presque de semaines on en a
fait une encore ce matin au moment où on
se parle bon on va essayer de recueillir
des indices sur les otages il y a des
négociations qui sont en cours donc donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans les jours
suivants mais mais Israël devait aussi
surveiller un autre front il y avait pas
que le front avec Gaza qui était
problématique là si je peux dire mais il
y avait aussi le front avec le Liban
avec le le Hezbollah libanais et il y a
aussi toute la S Jordanie qui bouillonne
en ce moment là toutes les frontières
d'Israël tu sais c'est pour ça qu'il
parle en front parce qu'il y a tout déjà
eu des gares ouais avec avec avec Israël
tu c'est hzbollah est fort au Liban mais
est fort dans le sud proche de la
frontière l'autre frontière à part la S
Jordanie c'est avec la syérie h ok fait
faut comprendre à cette idée de front là
c'est que il y a c'est compliqué sur sur
à part la mer là c'est compliqué partout
ouais ou alors ce qui s'est passé c'est
que là il y a eu des négociations pour
la libération d'otage qui se passe en
coulisse il y en a quatre qui ont été
libérés les autres sont toujours dans la
bande de Gaza on a imposé un blocus
total donc le blocus existait déjà il
était pas total maintenant il est total
on a négocié ensuite des couloir
humanitaire ou une ouverture de Rafa
pour laisser passer des camions de
nourriture médicaments et d'eau et
pendant ce temps-là les tirs de
roquettes en provenance de Gaza sur
Israël se sont poursuivis et les
bombardements israéliens aussi se sont
poursuivis et dans les derniers jours on
a commencé à avoir des camions entrés
dans la bande de Gaza mais vraiment au
comptegoutte on parle de 15 20 camions
par jour il en faudrait 100 au moins
pour répondre aux besoins de la
population et comme tu l'as dit il y a
eu une demande de l'armée
israélienne pas mal au début de cette
guerre- làà donc on a demandé à 1,4
million de Palestiniens de quitter le
nord de la bande de Gaza vers le sud
donc tout ce qui est au nord de Wadi
Gaza qui est un petit cours d'eau là on
leura demandé de quitter vers le sud et
ce qui nous laissait croire une
opération terrestre imminente on on on
dit qu'elle est imminente depuis depuis
plus d'une semaine de semaines là donc
mais mais ça reste en tout cas dans le
discours politique une volonté d'Israël
de d'entrer dans la bande de Gaza pour
détruire le Hamas donc a ces gens-là qui
ont quitté pas tous hein il y en une
partie de ces gens-là qui ont quitté
vers le sud d'autres ont choisi de
rester même s'il y avait des
bombardements très intenses au nord de
la bande de Gazin en disant ben moi
d'une part j'ai nulle part où aller je
peux pas quitter mon quartier parce que
les routes autour sont bombardé il y a
encore des bombardements c'est dangereux
et l'autre chose qu'on a souvent entendu
c'est si je quitte je ne pourrais jamais
revenir donc on a peur de cet exil comme
en 1948 donc il y a des gens qui sont
restés sur place et ensuite et ouais ben
c'est ça il y a aussi des gens qui
savaient pas où aller pour être séc
exactement il av en fait il y a nulle
part dans la bande de Gaza où on peut
être en sécurité parce que même les
endroits sur entre guillemets donc le
sud de la bande de Gaza où Israël a
demandé aux Palestiniens de de se rendre
ça a été bombardé aussi à ces
endroits-là donc il y a eu beaucoup de
bombardements beaucoup de morts et donc
ben là la situation écoutez ça fait 20
jours depuis le début de la guerre
aujourd'hui et la situation humanitaire
elle est catastrophique là euh il y a le
tiers des hôpitaux qui ne peuvent plus
fonctionner il y a plus d'eau potable ou
presque plus d'eau potable à Gaza peu de
nourriture pas d'électricité euh comment
on fait fonctionner un hôpital dans ce
temps-là comment on fait fonctionner une
salle d'opération sans eau potable donc
là en ce moment il y a des médecins qui
utilise du vinaigre pour désinfecter des
PLA ou de l'eau contaminée ce qui est
hyper dangereux pas d'électricité donc
et pas de carburant donc on peut pas
faire rouler les générateurs pour avoir
de
l'électricité il y a des Nouveaux Nez
dans des incubateurs dont la vie est en
danger en ce moment ça ce sont quelques
exemples mais imaginez une vie normale
sans électricité sans carburant sans
nourriture sans eau potable c'est
extrêmement difficileile imagine une vie
normm c'est difficile de vivre en fait
non puis il y a des quartiers complets
de gaz qui ont été réduits en en cendre
c'est pas en cendre mais c'est des des
amas de béton simplement on le voit sur
les images satellites il y a plus rien
donc des quartiers entiers qui ont été
bombardés détruits donc des gens qui ont
perdu leurs maison j'avais des chiffres
mais c'est des proportion incroyable
c'est 40 45 % des unités d'habitation à
Gaza qui ont été détruites et ça fait
seulement 20 jour que la la guerre a
commencé donc ce que les Palestiniens
craignent en ce moment c'est de quitter
vers le sud de la bande de Gaza
qu'Israël occupe une partie de la bande
de Gaza et que la situation devienne
tellement étonnable qu'on finisse par
ouvrir Rafa donc la frontière avec
l'Égypte pour que les gens puissent se
réfugier dans le Sinaï et
qu'éventuellement Israël prenne leur
territoire donc c'est c'est ce qui
craignent le plus évidemment il y a les
bombes première préoccupation euh et il
craignent de de perdre leur territoire
mais tu sais il y a eu d'autres guerres
avant euh moi j'ai j'ai parlé à plein de
gens à Gaza qui m' m'ont dit d'habitude
ce qu' nous disent les gens de Gaza
c'est on est habitué on va passer au
travers on est capable ça va aller puis
c'est presque qui nous rassure là sur
WhatsApp mais cette fois-ci c'est pas ça
du tout on a des commentaires ou moi
j'ai des des messages dans le genre i
have no word donc j'ai pas de mot don't
forget me ne m'oublie pas les gens sont
désespérés parce que c'est c'est la
guerre la plus meurtrière et la plus
destructrice depuis déjà longtemps
depuis 2007 en fait donc c'est c'est du
jamais vu et les les Gazaoui sont
vraiment en en détresse en ce moment là
c'est c'est peu dire j'ai pas de mot
assez fort en fait pour décrire ce qu'il
vivent est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on a un
bilan aujourd'hui de des des des des
morts des blessés puis est-ce que ce
bilan là est fiable en fait c'est plus
de 700000 700000 pardon 700 7000 voilà
morts plus de 17000 blessés à ta
question est-ce que c'est un bilan qui
est fiable c'est selon le ministère de
la Santé
de Gaza donc par exemple le président
américain Joe Biden a remis en question
ce bilan là
hier personnellement je vois pas
pourquoi on remettrait en question ce
bilan là les secouristes les voient les
morts passés dans les hôpitaux et tout
ça j'ai j'ai pas de misère à croire
qu'il y a autant de morts que ça à voir
les images il y a aussi plus de toute
façon il y en a beaucoup sais sont
confirm oui mais c'est ça il y a plus
d'un millier de personnes puis ça c'est
c'est très conservateur comme chiffre de
gens qui sont pris en ce moment sous les
décombres et il y a 60 % des morts qui
sont soit des femmes ou des enfants donc
ça vous donne un peu le le portrait gaz
est très jeune il y a beaucoup sais jeux
dire même ben le moyené en général mais
il y a beaucoup d'enfants il y a
beaucoup d'ados donc puis puis tu sais
je trouve ça dommage parce que quand on
parle de gazon on parle en terme de
chiffres on parle pas en terme
d'histoire tu sais c'est c'est des
statistiques on on a 7000 morts 7000
personnes qui ont été tuées dans des
bombardements par exemple mais c'estes
7000 personnes là ce sont des mères de
famille des pères de famille c'est des
gens comme vous et moi des employés
d'ONG des journalistes des des des
médecins des
donc c'est c'est des chiffres qui sont
hors norme et ça va bien sûr s'alourdir
euh dans les dans les prochains dans les
prochains jours là à partir de quand
puis je je pose une question mais je me
doute que vous pourrez pas répondre à ça
mais tu sais à partir de combien de
civils combien d'innocents tué
on commence à parler d'un crime de
guerre mais tu sais un crime de je pense
que c'est pas une question de chiffre
hein d'abord c'est c'est je veux dire
tout ça peu importe si le chiffre était
plus élevé moins
élevé personne devrait devrait être pris
dans cet étau politique là et pris comme
comme une souris là qu' on peut rien
faire qu'on peut pas sortir puis même
cette idéelà là même s'il perdait tu
sais la plupart des gens en Gaza c'est
des déplacés vient pas de Gaza d'origine
leur famille 80 % ce sont des réfugiés
c'est déjà le le consé la conséquence de
d'autres crises mais tu sais disons là
que alors ça tout ça c'est très grave
puis j'espère que le système
international va avoir les outils pour
dealer avec mais avant même qu'on arrive
là j'espère que ça va juste arrêter là
parce que c'est ça la chose la plus
urgente pour que l'aide humanitaire
rentre pour que les les journaliste
arrête de se faire tuer pour qu'on
comprenne au moins ce qui s'est passé
puis que s'arrête alors c'est ça la
chose la plus urgente h puis il faut
comprendre malheureusement c'est que tu
sais les Palestiniens il y a eu
longtemps une espèce de discours
politique de soutien au moins du du
moins sur le plan du Moyen-Orient mais
ils ont pas vraiment de soutien pour
vrai là c'est-à-dire que disons que même
dans le pire de pire des cas qui
passeraiit par le la la frontière de
Rafa pour aller dans le sinï le sinï a
qui on s'entend sur un désert ok oui
c'est entouré par la mer mais c'est un
désert qu'est-ce que tu fais dans le
désert tu es pas plus euh rien à faire
là il y a une espèce de tu sais pour
avoir vécu en Égypte pour avoir vécu en
Syrie pour avoir passé beaucoup de temps
au Liban mais jeisussi à Jordanie tout
ça mais à l'extérieur des euh dans les
pays limitrophe malheureusement quand tu
es
palestinien il y a une méfiance ok tu
es-tu tues-tu associé alors il y a pas
de vraie
solidarité il y a même un caricaturiste
qui a fait sa carrière là-dessus ok nage
d'Ali je pense qu'il s'appelle il y a
une espèce des fois si vous pramenez au
moyenoran vous allez voir une caricature
que c'est un petit bonhom au aux mains
croisé puis tu le vois de dos et ça ça
symbolise l'hypocrisie du peuple arabe
par rapport à la cause palestinienne
c'estàdire que tout le monde dans les
discours politiques pendant longtemps
tous les leaders du du monde arabe
soit-disant on dit monde arabe mais on
les pays arabophon du Moyen orien ok on
utilisé la cause palestinienne pour
rallier pour dénoncer mais en fait
faisait très peu puis je dis pas que la
les pays occidentaux étent mieux ok je
dis rien mais c'est juste si on
s'imagine que où est-ce qui peuvent
aller pour survivre nulle part parce que
même dans ces pays-là ils acceptent plus
ils veulent plus ils veulent plus de
réfugier parce qu'ils se disent ah vous
allez être encore là dans des
générations et cetera peut-être que la
seul endroit où est-ce que la dynamique
est un peu différente politiquement
c'est la Jordanie parce que le roi de
Jordanie bon il a S mari une
Palestinienne ils ont plus de droit de
citoyenneté c'est loin d'être parfait
mais les Palestiniens qui sont
jordaniens peuvent un peu avoir cette
identité un peu double et vivre une vie
normale mais dans beaucoup
de dans beaucoup d'endroits on parle de
camp qui existe encore qui sont devenus
maintenant des tours d'appartement en
ciment ok où est-ce que les gens ont pas
les mêmes droits que le reste de la
population est-ce qu'ils sont indiqués
dans des dans des écoles d'ONR de l'ONU
donc tu sais ils sont un ils sont isolés
dans leur territoire mais ils sont
isolés dans la région aussi
donc c'est c'est c'est assez déprimant
de toute façon ces gensl je veux dire
même s'ils
vivent un calvaire ça
reste leur leur m patrie leur territoire
je dire ces gens-là ont pas nécessement
envie juste d'abandonner ce territoire
c'est ça mais c'est juste pour dire que
les options elles sont extrêmement
limitées ouais puis ils ont un
attachement à la terre qui qui est
vicérale nous comme québécois canadiens
on a peut-être moins on a jamais eu à se
battre en fait pour pour rester ici eux
ils ont eu à le faire puis lors de la
création de l'État d'Israël il y avait
des gens qui vivaient déjà sur le
territoire donc qui ont été déplacés
aussi qui ont été déplacés donc à Gazan
s Jordanie dans les pays dont parlait
Laurence donc l'attachement à la terre
est viscérale et comme tu l'as dit ils
ont n part d'autre où aller donc ils
veulent rester chez eux en fait h il v
un pays c'est c'est ce qui réclame
depuis la création de l'État d'Israël un
État indépendant palestinien mais plus
le temps passe moins c'est possible
c'est aujourd'hui moi ça me fait un peu
sourire quand j'entends des hommes
politiques dire donc
oui faut cesser le feu ou en tout cas
une trêve humanitaire et je prendre la
solution à deux états c'est pas très
réaliste parce que pendant longtemps il
y en a eu des négociations ok avec des
certaines conditions qui pourraient
permettre un un état Palestiniens qui
vivent côte à côte avec un état
israélien en paix certaines de ces
conditions entre autres celles sur les
frontières deviennent très très
compliqué parce que sans eu négociation
direct qui aboutisseent personne
devaittre toucher aux frontières mais on
a on a parlé de la colonisation plutôt
on parle aussi de la de l'accès
sécuritaire en sisjordanie par Israël
qui vient faire la patrouille la police
qui rentre dans la maison des gens sauf
dans quelques villes discretes et rare
comme nablous ou hbron et même là mais
sa alors cette solution là disons
qu'elle a été dans elle a eu une mort
programmée parce que même si on imagine
on est très idéaliste pendant un moment
qu'il va y avoir une table de
négociation comment tu négocies des
frontières alors que tu as un peu de
monde partout puis la sjordanie est
morcelé hein ça a l'air d'un gruyèire
c'est-à-dire que depuis les accords de
slow ben p pendant les accords de slelou
on a on a divisé le territoire donc
toutes les c'est dans la fin des années
90 ouais exactement et donc ben les
accords de slelou 93 95 donc on a pris
les villes palestiniennes donc par
exemple ramala naplous Bethléem tout ça
c'est la zone A et donc ça c'est
contrôlé à 100 % par l'Autorité
palestinienne autant les affaires
civiles que sécuritaires autour de ces
petites îles là si vous voulez il y a la
zone B donc là c'est des c'est partagé
entre euh l'armée israélienne pour les
affaires sécuritaires mais pour les
affaires civiles c'est l'autorité
palestinienne et tout le reste de la
sisjordanie ces zon C c'est 100 %
contrôlé par l'armée israélienne donc
comment on peut avoir un État
palestinien sur ce territoire là est-ce
que les colons israéliens qui sont au
nombre de
650000 maintenant en incluant Jérusalem
Est accepterait de vivre dans un état
palestinienus devait être une ville qui
aurait qui serait négociée avec un
statut international spéciale parce que
religieusement est tellement importante
pour tellement de monde il devait y
avoir des négociations spécifiquement
sur le statut de Jérusalem comme tel
ouais h si cette cet avenu làà est on on
peut difficilement l'imaginer
euh qu'est-ce que évidemment
que tout ce qu'on dit depuis tantôt on
souhaite un saesser le feu de toutes
parts là qu'est-ce qu'Israël peuvent
faire pour s'assurer de plus avoir des
des attaques comme celles qui ont vécu
parce que là je comprends absolument que
la réplique est est absolument atroce
puis qu' qu'il faut que ça se termine
une fois terminé
euh c'est quoi la piste de solution pour
que ça réarrive pas ouais non mais c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que qu'on
parle de la fin des attaques ou qu'on
parle de négociation de paix d'une
solution politique qui donne des droits
à tout le monde puis de quoi exister
tout ça si ça se passe dans ma vie je
vais être une personne absolument
heureuse
là mais surtout après des événements
comme ça c'est comment coexister après
ça tu sais ben là ce qu'il déess de
faire leur stratégie c'est d'éradiquer
le am masse mais la question c'est aussi
est-ce que c'est possible de l'éradiquer
la question B oui les infrastructures
oui on peut assassiner des leaders du
Hamas qui soit politique ou militaire
mais après le has c'est aussi une idée
c'est aussi un mouvement politique fait
partie des gens aussi est-ce que les
est-ce que est-ce qu'une situation
politique comme ça où est-ce que tant de
civil Meur moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que ça le potentiel de radicalisante
quoi stir de ça tu saisfant qui
grandit dans cet environnement là que
que son père s'est fait tuer que c'est
c'est
ça qui a tout perdu qui a plus aucun
espoir qui qui la guerre radicalise tout
le monde exactement que ce soit dans ce
pays-là ou ailleurs en Syrie ou en Irak
on l'a vu avec daesh les les jeunes se
radicalisent quand ils ont aucun avenir
devant eux puis aucune solution là c'est
c'est c'est universel je dirais h fait
que en fait bref même même les je pense
que même les Israéliens selon ce que je
lis dans la presse israélienne ne savent
pas quelle est la prochaine étape c'est
bien là le danger qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire une fois qu'on aura éradiqué le
Hamas est-ce qu'on occupe Gaza est-ce
qu'on contrôle le territoire mais est-ce
qu'on a envie de contrôler une
population qui sera hostile à Israël je
sais pas donc il y a des informations
qui ont
fué certains de mes
contacts chez affaire mondial Canada
entre autres qui ont dans leur carton
certaines hypothèses et l'une des
hypothèses ce serait que par exemple
Israël vide la bande de Gaza s'organise
pour que les gens quittent complètement
puis pour avoir la paix pour ne plus
avoir une population
ou le amass à côté et il y a d'autres
hypothèses dans les cartons qui sont que
israël va en profiter pour accélérer la
colonisation en S Jordanie donc pour des
raisons sécuritaires ou en tout cas
officiellement sécuritaires on va
annexer des grands pans de la sjordanie
notamment la zone C la zone B mais je
pense que tu sais cette idé là que tu
sais sil y a un espèce de chaos
politique que je pense que même les
experts en israë on la mis a à essayer
de prédire je pense que tout le monde
peut faire des scénarios
én onuttre AR au mê scénari des
scénarios très optimistes très
pessimistes mais là voilà c'est très le
scénario numéro 1 évidemment on connaît
pas les plans et les les motivations
derrière chaque move mais tu sais est-ce
qu'on peut penser que c'est
l'objectif sais ultime d'Israël de juste
comme essayer de déplacer ces gens-là
problè R
non mais on peut pas penser ça mais ça
fait partie là de des scénarios parce
que c'est sûr que le status qu est pas
possible il y les Israéliens
n'accepteront pas de vivre à côté du
Hamas ça c'est sûr c'est sûr ça a été
trop douloureux ce qu'ils ont vécu le 7
octobre donc ça c'est sûr que le statut
est pas possible maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il y aura moi s'il y a une chose que
j'ai bien apprise en vivant là-bas puis
en travaillant comme journaliste pendant
4 ans c'est que ne faites pas de
prédiction sur le conflit Israël
palestinien parce que vous allez être
surpris pr dans le détour il y a
toujours c'est complexe il y a plusieurs
acteurs qui ont des intérêts aussi dans
ce conflit là des acteurs bien sûr bon
les Palestiniens les Israéliens mais
aussi de façon beaucoup plus large il y
a toute une une géopolitique des acteurs
régionaux donc
eu moi je je je ne jouerai pas à la
maline en essayant de faire des
prédictions c'est pas possible ce sont
bien sûr que des hypothèses pour
l'instant mais une chose est sûre c'est
que le statut quo euh ça ça marche Pasir
que les choses bougentut-êre je peux
peut-être évoquer un scénario qui
m'inquiète puis j'espère encore qu'on va
être capable de de prévenir mais
évidemment on en a parlé il faut
prévenir la mort de civile additionnelle
puis toute cette dynamique de vengeance
faut la prévenir pour être sûr
que tout ce qui sort politiquement de
Gaza puis d'Israël soit pas encore plus
cruel les uns envers les autres que ça a
déjà été mais tu sais comme comme
canadien comme québécois on a un lien
particulier au Liban aussi par exemple
parce qu'on a énormément de gens
d'origine libanaise au Canada on a un
lien à travers la francophonie très fort
tu sais comme intellectuel euh aussi euh
expace de Moyen-Orient il y a tout une
espèce de monde intellectuel très fort
qui vient de berutth aussi faut se
souvenir que le Liban en particulier a
vécu beaucoup de crisees récemment euh
ben évidemment l'explosion dans le port
de beyouth euh il y a une crise
politique de corruption qui est liée
aussi à ça euh
puis le Hezbollah qui est un part qui
est un un groupe terroriste qui aussi un
parti politique qui est représenté de
manière formelle dans cette espèce de de
système politique où est-ce que il y a
des des des rôles préassignés que ça
soit à différentes entités politiques
moi je suis inquiète pour tout ce qui se
passe là puis je suis très inquiète pour
le Liban c'està-dire que je pense que ce
qui est très très
dangereux c'est que le dans cette espèce
de fragilité gouvernement de transition
politique au Liban je veux vraiment pas
que ça pète au Liban en plus parce que
c'est une énorme population qui est
aussi beaucoup souffert puis qui la qui
soutiennent pas nécessairement le
hzbollah mais comme les Palestiniens ils
peuvent aussi devenir le dommage
collatéral la punition collective de ce
qu'il peuvent pas contrôler cétait que
c'est le le hzbollah commence à attaquer
et là il y a il y a il y a un va vient
alors moi là ce qu'il faut prévenir
c'est le faut arrê c'est comme faut
protéger la vie des civiles puis il faut
vraiment prévenir que ça s'étend pas à
la région ça on est ça ça pas lieu
encore là faut que tout le monde fasse
tout ce qu'il peuvent pour que ça ait
lieu parce que si ça commence à aller au
Liban là ça va être hyper dur sais c'est
une leçon à tirer tout ça aussi puis si
la leçon aurait dû être faite avant là
c'est que les Israéliens ils ont une
expression pour gérer gaz il disait
toujours on va tondre le gazon
c'est-à-dire que c'est une stratégie
peut-être je vous en ai parlé quand je
vous ai visit entend ça la semaine
passée mais peut-être que qu'on s'en
parler aussi et donc c'est de dire au 2
3 4 ans on va on bombarde les capacités
militair du Hamas et donc de cette
façon-là le Hamas devient jamais assez
puissant pour représenter une menace pu
c'est une façon pour Israël aussi euh de
de diviser les Palestiniens et de ne pas
négocier la paix avec eux parce que
Israël dit on peut pas négocier avec
deux acteurs différents un seul
interlocuteurtin ils sont en guerre
exactement emble le Hamas pas négocier
exactement
donc ça ça servait bien le statut quo
d'une certaine manière Israël qui
pouvait poursuivre son entreprise de
colonisation entre autres en S Jordanie
et donc là cette stratégie là de couper
le gazon mais aussi de construire des
murs que ce soit celui de Gaza ou celui
en sjordanie de poursuivre la
colonisation et l'occupation clairement
c'est une stratégie qui ne mènera jamais
à la paix et qui ne fonctionne pas ni
pour assurer la sécurité des
Palestiniens ni pour assurer leur propre
sécit préend eu même que ça va mener à
la
paix le gouvernement s'est jamais dit
qu' était pour la paix mais clairement
les murs céit contenit cétait de faire
comme si ça ça se contenait comme
clairement les murs et le blocus ce sont
pas des solutions pour assurer leur
propre sécurité on en a eu la
preuve tantôt tu tu sais tu
tu tu posais la question comment qu'on
va se souvenir de ce conflit là comment
qu'on va le regarder plus tard puis tu
sais tantôt je posais la question à
partir de combien de de de civils on on
commence à à dire ben là ça c'est pas
juste une guerre normale tu sais puis
surtout de nos jours tu sais l'armée
israélienne les armées justement les
mieux outillés les mieux équipés les
mieux entraînés tout ça qu'on soit
encore à la technique de d'envoyer des
roquetes des roquettes sur un territoire
puis qui a autant
de de dommages collatéraux je peux pas
croire qui a pas de manière plus précise
de frapper plus efficace de viser plus
directement seulement les membres du
esbola sans qu'il a autant de CIV du
amas autant de civils qui meurent est-ce
qu'on va regarder ça plus tard puis puis
est-ce qu'on va juger ça puis condamner
ça j'ai envie de est-ce que je peux
proposer quelque chose j'ai envie de
dire que tu sais moi j'ai un petit
garçon là qui est très jeune j'ai
l'impression que quand ils vont regarder
notre génération ils vont pas se poser
la question sur la qu ils vont se poser
une question beaucoup plus large que ça
h ils vont se dire coup don tu sais vos
parents vos grands-parents ils sont
battus en sortant de la deuxè Guerre
mondiale pour bâtir des outils d'un
système multilatéral qui éosé de faire
en sorte que la paix fonctionne ok qui a
des cours pénal international qui a des
casques bleus qui a l'eau nu ça a jamais
été parfait ok mais il y avait des
choses qui existaient qui ont été bâtis
avec une vision très
occidentalocentrée le sud global qu'on
en comme en sortant la de guerre
mondiale tout le monde faisait comme ça
existait pas là puis ou bien c'est
encore colonisé puis ça allait se
décoloniser avec plein de dynamique
post-colonial aussi après mais je pense
qu'ils vont se dire comment vous avez
abandonné parce que là on est rendu
malheureusement là ça tout ça explose
c'est c'est c'est horrible parce qu'on a
laissé faire puis parce que la la
majorité des pays occidentaux dont le
Canada a décidé qu'on s'inquiétait plus
du Moyen-Orient tout le monde a dit il y
a rien à faire avec le conflit Israël au
Palestiniens on va pas dépenser
l'énergie politique là-dedans ça marche
pas les derniers leaders que qui ont COM
qui ont fait des dernières effort pour
essayer de négocier quelque chose sous
Obama John carry essayit quelque chose
Tony Blair a essayit quelque chose mais
rien marchait fait un peu c'était vu
comme le cimetière des bonnes intentions
diplomatiques fait il ont dit il y a
rien à gagner làdans on laisse faire
puis on ignore mais la réalité c'est que
tu peux pas juste faire une stratégie
puis avoir une priorité puis dire moi
c'est ma dans le commerce en Asie on a
une parce que on est on on est des pays
privilégiés développé parce que beaucoup
des grandes puissances ont été des
puissances coloniales dans ces
régions-là on a une responsabilité comme
communauté internationale puis j'ai
envie de dire que la prise de conscience
elle commence pas maintenant elle
commence à comment on a commencé on a à
abandonner la construction de ce système
multilatéral là qui est supposé d'avoir
des processus pour négocier la paix pour
soutenir les civils la Charte des droits
humains maintenant il y a des gens qui
disent là que la Déclaration Universelle
des Droits Humains qui dont fête
l'anniversaire cette année elle serait
plus jamais écrite aujourd'hui tout le
monde se battrait sur l'écriture de ce
qui est puis de ce qui est quelque chose
d'assez simple et banal dans le terrain
de base ouais ouais c'est juste comme la
dignité humaine les alors moi je me dis
c'est Gaza ok c'est Gaza aujourd'hui
puis j'espère ça sera pas Gaza demain
mais en vent c'est terrible puis puis
dans notre génération c'est une grande
cicatrice puis mais il y a aussi Haïti
il y a aussi l'Ukraine il y a plein de
choses ce qu'on les femmes en
Afghanistan qu'on a qu'on a abandonné je
pense que c'est pas juste parce qu'on
pense toujours que notre époque est plus
importante mais je pense que
malheureusement ce qui marque notre
époque c'est c'est un abandon du système
multilatéral et ça c'est extrêmement
grave je suis d'accord sur la
responsabilité collective puis pour
répondre à si concrètement à ta question
Israël a la capacité de faire des
frappes ultra précises on l'a vu dans le
passé quand il ciblait par exemple des
dirigeants du Hamas ou avec un certain
type de missile je suis pas experte en
balistique mais où il y avait juste
l'appartement dans un gros building qui
avait été détruit donc il y a ça mais
ben ils peuvent le faire mais je vais
ajouter un
met si leur but c'est d'éradiquer le
Hamas faut savoir que la Hamas a tout un
réseau de tunnel c'est des centaines de
kilomètres sous terre
et ça pour neutraliser ces tunnels là
donc pour les détruire on détruit
nécessairement des quartiers
résidentiels pour détruire des des
entrepôts d'armes et tout ça souvent tu
sais la bande de Gaza on le dit depuis
tantôt c'est tout petit c'est danssément
peuplé c'est une quarantaine de
kilomètres par une douzaine de
kilomètres et donc nécessairement les
entrepôts d'armes et tout ça ça peut
être dans un quartier résidentiel ou à
proximité donc le has c'est fait partie
physiquement de cette population là je
suis pas en train de dire que donc on
peut bombarder puis puis c'est pas grave
qu'il y a des victimes civiles au
contraire mais c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de d'éradiquer le Hamas sans
faire de de victimes civiles pour ces
raisonsl entre autres si on veut
détruire tous les tunnels couper leur
armement puis cibler les dirigeants ben
nécessairement c'est des bombardements
de grande ampleur puis pour aller euh
frappe terrestre une guérila dans des
dans des villes sur le territ
est- contrôlé par la hamass en fait
c'est des victimes militair
israéliennees par probablement milliers
ben l'opération terrestre ça va être un
peu compliqué parce que on risque
d'assister à des Combas de rue c'est le
territoire le terrain de jeu du Hamas je
vous le disais il y a des tunnel donc
par exemple et déjà tous ces tunnels là
puis les bâtiments ont été piégés en
amont parce que le des étages aussi qui
sont
cach sont cachés s ouais probablement et
donc ils ont ils ont pris prévu cette
opération là contre Israël donc
probablement qu' y a beaucoup de pièges
et tout ça donc ça va être compliqué
pour l'armée israélienne et ça risque de
coûter cher en vie humaine par exemple
ils peuvent utiliser un tunnel pour
sortir en arrière ils peuvent être sur
le le toit de certains grands bâtiments
tirer des roquettes sur le toit d'un
temps qui est beaucoup plus fragile que
les côtés bon et donc oui ça va être
compliqué et coûteux de d'entrer
physiquement avec des troupes au sol que
ça me fait penser peut-être visuellement
la dernière opération de ce type qui
était extrêmement médiatisé c'est pas
exactement la même chose mais c'est
quand en irac ils essayent de reprendre
Moussou qui était contrôlé par Da on
voyait vraiment de rue à rue de coin de
rue à coin de rue toute la complexité
d'une ville à moitié détruite dans ça va
ressembler c'est pas la même chose he
puis y a d'autres enjeux mais ça va
ressembler à ce que visuellement vu dans
la reprise de dans la prise de mousou
donc c'est pour ça qui pour l'instant
j'imagine se garde une g de de rentrer
là complètement je pense je sais pas je
tu sais on peut pas savoir la stratégie
mais ça fait longtemps qu'il en parle
parce que c'est trop dangereux parce que
à cause des civils à cause de beaucou à
cause des otages aussi des pressions
américaines en ce moment pour dire
retarder votre opération terrestre parce
qu'on est en train de négocier en
coulisse pour la libération de plusieurs
otages donc il y a ça il y a aussi que
si il déplace beaucoup de troupes vers
Gaza ben tu dégarnis d'autres fronts
notamment la sjordanie où il y a eu
beaucoup de tension depuis le début on
parle pas de la S Jordanie an mais il y
a eu une centaine de palestiniens qui
ont été tués euh dont une trentaine
d'enfants d'adolescents dans des heures
avec dans des affrontements avec l'armée
israélienne il y a eu beaucoup de
Palestiniens qui ont été victimes
d'attaque des colons aussi israéliens
tout ça ce sont des conséquen bien sûr
des des tensions entre Gaza et Israël ou
entre Israël et le Hamas donc faut pas
non plus
dégarnir d'autres fronts parce que ça
peut être compliqué donc il y a plein de
stratégies militaires comme ça qui
doivent analyser mais ils ont aussi des
pressions extérieur pour dire attendez
avant de faire une opération terrestre
et surtout vous allez faire quoi de Gaza
après avant d'entrer faudrait peut-être
connaître le prochain coup là après
faudrait peut-être connaître le prochain
coup
ouais merci beaucoup c'était fascinant
puis on on va essayer de à moins que
tuas quelque chose à rajouter moi ça
fait non non mais je pense qu'on a fait
à moins que il y ait des points que vous
avez aimé parler qu'on a pas parlé je
pense qu'on ça nous donne une
compréhension vraiment meilleure de de
la situation on va essayer de sortir le
podcast le plus rapidement possible je
pense puis merci pour l'invitation c'est
tellement important d'en parler parce
que c'est polarisé donc il y a beaucoup
d'explication puis de travail
d'éducation à faire sur ce confl merci
beaucoup